The Shinobi crouched low on the pagoda roof
and listened to the night air.
Up here in the mountains, away from the hustle
and bustle of the markets in town, it was
almost silent.
Just the distant rattle of shutters somewhere
behind him.
The mountain shrine was tucked out of sight,
so far into the countryside that no one would
stumble onto it by accident.
No one would come here without a reason.
The Shinobi knew the face of his target, a
warlord turned politician, with more blood
on his hands than the assassin sent to kill
him.
By the burning glow of the night sky, the
Shinobi could see the man kneeling at the
shrine.
The path was made up of small stones, so he’d
have to drop onto the grass and creep around
the pond to approach his target.
No guards, no one else was there at all.
This was the spot where the man came to pray
when he was struggling to sleep, perhaps trying
to atone for the lives he’d taken.
Perhaps he didn’t care at all.
The ninja drew the blade in total silence
and timed his drop to the ground with the
rattling noise in the distance.
With each dainty step, he closed the distance
to his target, readying the blade over his
head.
It was done in a moment.
The man was dead before his body hit the ground.
He likely didn’t even notice as the steel
had severed the nerves running down his spinal
cord.
So shard was the blade that it slid through
his bones like a fish through water.
Raising the blade to his eyes, the Shinobi
cleaned it quickly.
If he was seen with blood on his sword, he
would immediately be implicated, not that
he was ever seen.
But precautions like this were what kept him
out of sight for all of these years.
When you lived in the Valley of Ashes, the
burial grounds for countless wars, you had
to become a shadow, become one of the ancient
spirits haunting the woods.
But as he wiped the red from the steel, he
caught a flash of light in the reflection.
An orange glow marking a jagged line across
the metal.
That’s strange, sunset was several hours
ago.
Come to think of it, why was there an orange
glow in the sky?
He snapped his neck around to see the fires
through the gates into the pagoda’s garden.
Down by the ocean’s edge, at the foot of
the mountains, was the city where he has always
lived.
And it was on fire.
Leaping up onto the walls, he stood up straight,
surveying the horror scene taking place before
him.
Thick plumes of smoke billowed up into the
night sky, so dense and large that it seemed
to become the blackness of the night.
It was hard to make out much of what was going
on down there.
The Shinobi looked everywhere to try to see
the invading army or the rioters, but there
were none.
Just people running in all directions like
ants out of a flooding nest.
But there, moving in amongst the smoke, were
other shapes, impossibly tall, lumbering around
like… people.
People that towered over the houses, that
had to crane down to the ground to scoop up
the poor civilians who were running this way
and that.
The Shinobi stood there, terrified, as he
realized the rattling sound he’d been hearing
all night wasn’t from any shutters at all.
He could do nothing but watch as the trees
in front of him trembled and buckled in all
directions, as a hulking shadowy figure lumbered
towards him.
*
The Imperial Japanese Anomalous Matters Examination
Agency, or the IJAMEA, was a Japanese agency
responsible for tracking a number of mysterious
and often dangerous artifacts, creatures and
anomalies, prior to the Second World War.
In 1945, the IJAMEA was shut down and absorbed
into the SCP Foundation.
All of these data, historic records, and anomalies,
were all transferred over into the Foundation’s
control.
Reasons for this were partially political
and partially in the interest of world peace.
The formation of the IJAMEA was influenced
heavily by Japan’s ties with Germany in
the first half of the 20th century.
The Imperial German Anomalous Matters Examination
Agency was the blueprint for their Japanese
equivalent.
However, with increasing militarism in Japan
throughout the 20th century, the IJAMEA became
increasingly obsessed with trying to harness
their anomalous discoveries in the interests
of military power.
Their goal became the establishment of a Yokai
Battalion, powerful enough to establish them
as one of, if not the world’s greatest superpower.
Following the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
Japan surrendered in the Second World War
and agreed to dissolve its military, including
the IJAMEA.
That left the Foundation with the task of
picking up the threads left behind and trying
to come up with new ways of securing, containing,
and protecting some of Japan’s most deadly
SCPs.
Few more deadly and evasive than the entities
that were too much even for the Yokai Battalion.
SCP-2863.
*
In 1946, clean-up operations were in full
effect, trying to deal with the fallout from
the atomic bomb dropped on Nagasaki.
Crews dressed in led-lined suits worked around
the clock burying radioactive material and
trying to remove as much contaminated debris
as possible.
Rebuilding the city was still a long way off.
At various points, the wind would kick up
and carry the dust left behind into the air,
creating a dangerous radioactive haze.
Crews continued to work through such conditions
as the understanding of airborne contamination
was still in its infancy.
Watanabe Goro was one such worker.
Midway through a night shift and clasping
a damp rag to his mouth, he pushed on through
the dust, clearing out building after building.
They had spent the morning carrying corpses
out of an unidentifiable building.
The corpses themselves were pretty much worn
away too.
Just skeletons, really, charred by the blast
from months before.
As Goro staggered along the street, he kept
feeling like he was imagining things.
The long hours and traumatic conditions were
enough to make him see all kinds of things
in his dreams, but he kept feeling like his
dreams were starting to creep into the real
world.
Shadows kept moving through the haze all around
him, taller than buildings, staggering around
as if they were drunk.
They had been appearing all night, just out
of sight, but always close by.
He stopped and leaned against what was left
of a brick wall.
There was one of his hallucinations now, just
up ahead of him.
The husks of buildings on either side of him
were about as tall as their knees.
It must have been thirty meters tall, at least.
But its legs were strange, there seemed to
be a gap in the middle of each of them.
They were skinny, no… skeletal.
The skeleton’s foot crushed a car right
in front of him.
The crunch of metal was loud enough to snap
Goro out of his stupor.
This wasn’t a hallucination.
Hallucinations can’t crush cars.
With a yelp, he tumbled backwards, staring
up into the haze of dust.
He saw the shadow of a pelvis, above it what
must have been a ribcage the size of his house,
but the creature disappeared into the darkness
and the dust.
If it was too tall for him to see its face,
maybe it was too tall to see him on the ground
as well.
The skeleton stopped, standing directly over
him.
For a second, he thought that maybe he’d
be okay.
But then, with a great rattling rumble, the
monster hunched down low, and the enormous
skull appeared out of the haze, flying right
toward him.
He managed to dodge its gnashing teeth, but
it caught his foot, sending him rolling through
the radioactive dirt.
Goro didn’t give himself a moment to recover,
though, he took off running as fast as he
could, hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
close behind his back.
*
You will be pleased to know that Watanabe
Goro survived this incident.
With only minor injuries, he managed to navigate
his way to the nearest police station, where
SCP agents, already familiar with the entity
he had encountered, took control of the situation.
The so-called Starving Skeletons had been
roaming the bomb sites for several weeks by
that point.
It was the Foundation’s first exposure to
one of the oldest known entities that the
IJAMEA had been studying for years.
To date, 206 separate instances of SCP-2863
have been officially recorded.
However, the myth of the Gashadokuro has been
circulating in various parts of Japan since
the tenth century at least.
Giant skeletons were said to haunt the sites
of particularly deadly battles, hunting by
night and feeding on the blood of their human
victims.
These myths tally up with what the Foundation
currently knows about these entities.
Instances of SCP-2863 only appear after sunset
and will lose all corporeality when exposed
to sunlight in the morning or any light source
over 1.1 lux.
To give you some reference for that, moonlight
typically falls between 0.25 and 1 lux.
A typical room with the light on will be one
hundred or even one thousand times brighter.
As you can imagine, this has made them virtually
impossible to contain as they manifest and
unmanifest outside of controllable conditions.
They seem to have continuous existence in
some way however, as previously neutralized
instances can and will reappear later on.
In folklore, the Gashadokuro are spirits that
take control of skeletons.
Some hesitant researchers have posited that
perhaps the instances that dematerialize are
returning to their spirit form.
Little is understood about what that means
in practice.
What is more, this SCP cannot be photographed.
All attempts to capture them on film or digital
cameras have failed, including video tests.
It is theorized that there is a link between
them not appearing on camera and their disappearance
when exposed to light.
Again, quite what link could be is still mostly
unknown.
Due to a steady increase in urban development
in Japan and ongoing peace in the region,
appearances of this SCP are growing increasingly
rare.
While this marks a positive change for the
people of Japan, it makes it even more difficult
to study this SCP and learn how to prevent
it in the future.
The most recent fatality to occur at the bony
hands of SCP-2863 happened in 2008, and it
was as part of a Foundation experiment.
While most of Hiroshima and Nagasaki have
been redeveloped into bustling metropolitan
areas, the outskirts of each city, particularly
several parks, saw occasional instances of
SCP-2863 appearing at night.
As such, the SCP Foundation conducted a series
of experiments under cover of nightfall, releasing
D-class personnel into a park in Hiroshima
to observe how the SCPs hunted humans.
Their enormous height, towering at over 30m,
gave them a huge advantage, being able to
chase people down with little difficulty.
Another notable thing about them is just how
quietly they move.
There is a gentle rattling sound that follows
them around, but aside from that, they are
very light-footed and difficult to detect
until they are right on top of you.
This isn’t helped by the fact that they
hunt at night.
As a result, they are remarkably quick at
catching their prey.
Once they have snatched their victims up in
their skeletal fingers, they perform the same
eating ritual every time.
They eat the person and consume their blood.
Initially confused by this finding, the Foundation
was unsure where the blood was going as the
skeletons had no obvious digestive system.
After the release of several more D-class
personnel into the park, they still weren’t
certain but believed that the SCP instances
were absorbing the blood into their bones
in some way.
Further testing was requested but denied due
to the sheer number of D-class fatalities
in the area.
They were starting to run out, and would have
to ship more of them across to Japan, which
was just a bit inconvenient for everyone involved.
As the outskirts of those cities have been
urbanized, the instances of SCP-2863 have
reduced to the point that a smaller contingent
of agents and researchers are now left in
place.
The light pollution from these areas is enough
to prevent them from being able to manifest
in the first place for the most part.
Only on the rare occasion of power outages
have Mobile Task Force 03 been deployed.
Whilst researching this SCP, the Foundation
came across an account from a Shinobi in the
1700s.
It was rare to find any kind of written document
from a ninja for obvious reasons, but the
account discovered painted a harrowing picture
of just how much damage these Yokai could
inflict upon a city.
The nameless Shinobi first encountered SCP-2863
while assassinating an unnamed target in the
mountains above his fishing town.
Looking down on the fires below him, he saw
human shapes walking through the smoke, dwarfing
the buildings they moved between, before an
instance charged through the trees straight
at him.
Diving out of the way, the Shinobi quickly
melted into the shadows.
Both man and demon hunted one another through
the night.
He managed to climb onto its spine and inflict
what he was certain would be a killing blow
to the skeleton, only for his blade to bounce
right off the bone.
Caught and vulnerable for the first time in
his life, the Shinobi was helpless as the
spirit threw him from its back into the courtyard
and charged at him.
It was only the hem of the ninja’s sleeve
catching fire from a candle that saved him.
Just as the skeleton was about to bite down
on his head, the light flared, and the SCP
disappeared entirely.
For a long while, the man lay in the courtyard,
pondering his actions.
He should have died that night, yet he survived.
Getting slowly to his feet, the man knew now
what his destiny was.
A monster that strikes from the shadows, scared
of the light.
He and the Gashadokuro were not so different.
Understanding his target was the step to defeating
them.
Snatching up a lantern from the ground, the
Shinobi descended the mountain into the wreckage
of his hometown and defended his people.
By night, he would emerge hunting down the
Gashadokuro under the cover of darkness, banishing
them with the light hidden under a dark sheet.
The man fought night after night, narrowly
risking death, to save his people from the
onslaught of the evil spirit.
A small plaque was installed by the IJAMEA
shortly before the Foundation took over the
management of the SCP.
It was installed at the foot of an old pagoda
just outside a small fishing village.
On it was a simple haiku.
Walking in shadow,
In the midst of our demons,
We will find the light.
Now check out “SCP-2662 - Cthulhu” and
“SCP–2935 – O, Death!”